if I could live inside the world of any
film let's see what comes to mind would
be
if I could live inside the world of any
Film It Is A Hard Day's Night Richard
Lester and the Beatles the friendship
that was exemplified by these four guys
who just seemed to be having the
greatest time of their lives doing what
they naturally love to do it Remains the
most joyful movie I've ever seen maybe
Paris Blues is Paris it's the 40s 50s
it's jazz music and it's Diane Carroll
and Sidney Poitier well my like
eight-year-old self would say the movie
Hook that scene when Robin Williams is
there and he Scoops up this pile of
whipped cream and they have this food
fight and I just like so desperately
wanted to live in a world where if I
just imagined a pile of flavored whipped
cream it would just appear before me I
wouldn't live inside the world of my
neighbor total the Pastoral beauty of
that place and you're surrounding my
Woods that are mythical and home and
full of stories and Spirits I think
probably be a rear window actually they
grew up with an obsession of seeing all
those different little boxes with all
the different Little People in and I had
an absolute like real obsession with
Grace Kelly crazy Rich Asians the
wedding scene when the water poured down
the aisle I was like I'll just grab a
canister of water and pour down out when
I'll get married just so it's just like
somewhere in the same space I'd live in
the Chocolate Factory
wouldn't want to live in
Willy Wonka's chocolate factory I just
feel like it would be bright and joyous
and colorful and quite tasty call me by
your name I just want to be on a bike
in Tuscany in the summer just waiting
for my next pasta meal would be the best
I would love to live in the lady Eve
there's something very old Hollywood and
beautiful about it I think it would be
it's a mad mad world a lot of funny
people there and then it would probably
be fast and furious they always seem to
have the nicest car and they have the
freedom to like not have to worry about
insurance you know jumping from
buildings and not worried about what's
that price tag going to be they don't
ever have to pay for anything but they
always have a nice car you can actually
live in that fabricated world I would
love to